hey 42 here in late 2019 Empire magazine
run an interview with Martin Scorsese
that for a brief moment said the
internet on fire
discussing Scorsese's filmmaking kiss to
me the great director was asked for his
opinion on the current state of cinema
in particular the Marvel Cinematic
Universe his response angered a lot of
people equate 'uncle movies to theme
park rides
he stated they aren't cinema and went on
to say they aren't the cinema of human
beings trying to convey emotional
physiological experiences to another
human being this is of course a nice way
of saying they're at best
shallow entertainment at worst nonsense
only good for watching when you want to
put your brain into sleep mode when it
came to putting in the effort to watch
these kinds of movies the best he could
muster was a mere I tried the response
was fairly emphatic people argued on the
news the head of Disney was so angered
he arranged to meet up with coursezi to
convince him he was wrong various actors
and film industry professionals
commented but Scorsese doubled down
stating in the New York Times that the
Marvel movies were devoid of genuine
revelation mystery emotional danger and
that nothing was at risk and they were
inhospitable to art so in general
statements were flying this way that way
and all over the place and you know what
Scorsese was right but he was right in
perhaps more ways than he knew or even
liked to admit modern cinema especially
that encapsulated by the MCU and similar
franchises does suck we've gone from the
fort provoking visual masterpieces of
the Godfather trilogy Citizen Kane a
Clockwork Orange and Apocalypse Now and
hundreds of us but each in their own way
advanced the cinematic medium and
artistic
human achievement to modern tribe such
as transformers white chicks
50 shades cats and dare I speak its name
the emoji movie and an absolute slew of
endless animated and superhero
franchises that handles terrible sequel
after terrible prequel after terrible
spin-off occasional gems do surface from
the cesspit just to name a selection of
my personal favorite recent releases of
course yours may differ the grand
Budapest hotel darkest hour joker almost
everything by Christopher Nolan and much
by the Coen brothers and Scorsese's own
the Irishman but on the whole cinema is
in a very dark place right now
and has been for some time now a lot of
this video may come across as the
grumblings of someone whose generation
is being replaced with a younger one
with different more spandex Laden tastes
I'm man enough to admit that it's been
shown that there's a certain age your
taste in music set in stone so it's
perfectly possible it's the same for
movies and therefore my tastes are just
set in the past and I'll never get what
all the fuss is about
so maybe I'm just a mustache commotion
who can't get with the times that's
possibly true
no it's definitely true don't get me
wrong when I watch modern blockbusters I
do enjoy them I feel a frill a Scorsese
suggested it's as if I'm on a ride in an
amusement park I laugh anticipate and
sometimes shed a tear and it's all good
fun however I certainly don't find
myself salivating at the prospect of
seeing another one nor do I derive any
deeper meaning from them so maybe it's
just me oh maybe just maybe the movie
industry has been debased to a deluge of
detritus and my viewpoint has some
veracity and I'll tell you why I think
this is
the way I see it there are two main
reasons why modern movies are on the
whole fairly awful and those are
business and storytelling for simplicity
I'm going to split this video into these
two sections let's start with business
first we need to establish how the movie
business has now become an almost
perfect engine for producing garbage why
because every element of it is designed
to do exactly that rather than make
something spectacular the movie industry
is inherently inclined to make something
mediocre and more often than not that's
exactly what they aim for because
mediocrity sells there are several
reasons why mediocrity is actually the
industry-wide goal one of the most
glaring and absurd is that movies are
frequently made for no other reason than
to preserve the rights to characters
characters are essentially assets that
can be utilized by the company ie Disney
or Sony to produce income if the company
does not use the character in a film the
rights to that character often revert
meaning they lose the asset ever wonder
why there was a Hellraiser movie that
was filmed in just two weeks
countless spider-man reboots Fantastic
Four reboots or even insanely a Jason
Bourne movie that didn't actually star
Jason Bourne the studio wanted to put
something out to preserve the rights and
in the latter case Matt Damon was busy
so bafflingly we got some of the guy who
wasn't Jason Bourne am I the only one
who thinks that's insane these movies
are made essentially in the hope that
keeping the right will pay off later
down the line in the meantime here's
your crappy half-assed movie enjoy or
not we don't care characters should
operate as artistic apparatus that aid
storytelling express meaningful emotion
and ultimately a
- the movie experience enabling the
viewer to connect with it on a more
personal level but today characters are
just base assets that can be monetized
no actually is more than that characters
are now entire brands and characters
like Batman James Bond Harry Potter or
Superman are brands that in and of
themselves bring in hundreds of millions
of dollars through games merchandising
licensing toys and films spider-man the
most popular superhero in the world
brings in over a billion in other words
these characters are as profitable to
their parent companies as Air Jordans
are to Nike or the iPhone is to Apple
think about that for a second and
there's nothing wrong with these
characters becoming brands so long as
the quality of the movies doesn't suffer
but it's essential that these brands are
kept alive in the public consciousness
to keep them earning money and keep
those assets profitable how do you do
that through a constant bombardment of
new mediocre movies it's also imperative
that these brands as the ad agency Young
& Rubicam declared become the new
religion which is something I'll leave
you to process but given the visceral
Martin Scorsese was subjected to I'd say
marvel at the very least have been very
successful at spawning a devout
following if I'm being cynical this is
no doubt one of the motivations behind
the shared universe craze that has
gripped movie studios in the last decade
if you take a gamble on audiences
responding positively to a brand new
character you can buffer the audience's
expectations by inserting an already
well-known character brand into the
narrative that way you get a new and
existing audience all in one go
regardless of whether it benefits the
story in any way
for example Batman V Superman was rammed
full of tacked-on superhero
introductions spider-man - not the
recent sequel order Tobey Maguire one
the other one no not the animated one
the one with the guy of the long nap
yeah that one that Spiderman - tried to
set up a universe of villains Tom
Cruise's The Mummy tried to set up a
universe of monsters the issue was that
none of the producers stopped to think
perhaps we should actually make this one
a decent movie why characters equals
assets equals brands equals franchises
equals money money money
but why do all studios these days have
to be like this why is it always the
same regurgitation recipe well movies
are an incredible financial risk
complete with thousands of moving parts
that are incredibly unlikely to succeed
you can have a great director and great
actors but if the script sucks you're
going nowhere
you can have a great script but if the
marketing blows you'll get no return and
so on it's incredibly easy to fail so
Hollywood has become extremely adept at
predicting what works and sticking to it
don't take my word for it here's Fight
Club director David Fincher talking
about moviemaking within the studio
system he said if you want to make
studio movies you stay in their lanes
which are romantic comedy affliction
Oscar bait spandex summer superhero
tentpole moderately budgeted sequel and
aside from how hilarious affliction
Oscar bait is that shows how constricted
the largest engine of moviemaking the
studio system has become and more often
than not filmmakers need these kinds of
engines or their idea won't see the
light of day filmmaking is an incredibly
expensive art form unlike almost all the
others it requires hundreds of thousands
if not hundreds of millions to see a
vision come to life when novelists need
a vocabulary persistence and a word
processor filmmakers need a crew of
hundreds and a blank check so it's
completely understandable why most
movies end up being semi repetitive
rubbish they have no choice but to be
from a financial perspective and if the
studio is fronting the cash why
shouldn't they make good on their
investment I'd want to the poor sod
whose original idea the film was has to
let the studio tear it apart and feed it
into their brand the creation mass
market money-making machine because the
alternative is that the film doesn't get
made but for the film lovers out there
like you and me we get what a trash year
after year but don't worry it gets worse
because the market itself has changed
and he's had some ugly consequences you
see in the past when it came to film
there was America and a few smaller
international markets but America was by
far the biggest single market if America
didn't like a movie it tended to flop
now however things have seriously
changed the China's market size is
rapidly on the rise rivaling America's
and this means one thing if a movie is
going to ensure its financial success it
needs to translate across many different
cultures
this means intellectually and morally
complex dialogue heavy plots like there
will be blood and dr. Strangelove aren't
ideal but flash special effects heavy
action entertainment who have easily
translatable simple themes ie good guys
versus bad guys is the ideal product
choice and the bigger foreign markets
gets the more this trend will continue
most character brands such as James Bond
spider-man and Superman are already
established images you don't need a
complex plot to recognize them you need
a wealth of PPK
a web shooter and the red cape people
recognize this image that
instantaneously pulled into the story
incan now kick back watch a load of
stuff blower
enjoy the ride in other words the brands
translate across cultures through
visuals alone ever wonder why superhero
movies are everywhere these days because
they are simple images with simple
themes that anyone of any culture can
understand they won't challenge your
preconceptions or improve your life in
any way but they go down as easily as
the film equivalent of Big Mac and Fries
but for your health but damn does it
taste good how movies are marketed has
also become an issue the social media
has changed the game more than ever with
a movie living or dying by how it is
received on social media in a few
minutes everyone can know how much your
film stinks and bad reviews can go viral
in the past a bad movie but stay hidden
long enough to make it four turns
relying solely on the revenue from the
weekly cinema guru who picks around the
movie market but that market is now all
but dead this has only increased the
risk of moviemaking more than ever and
thus the need for studios to predict and
control the outcome this is an all-time
high so today the first question asked
by movie studios is not whether the film
is good but can it actually be sold but
this isn't the long-term definition of
sold is to short term definition that
being the opening weekend because of how
movie financing works a movie needs to
double its costs in grosses to even
break even films cost hundreds of
millions to make Plus even more hundreds
of millions to market and distribute a
tentpole blockbuster like Iron Man a
free for instance would have to gross
over 750 million just to land on its
feet spoiler it did to make matters
worse movies have a crazy drop-off
weekend to weekend and the vast majority
of profits are made on the opening
weekend sure occasionally home
like Avatar come along that eat weekend
grosses over and over and over again but
by and large movies have a punishingly
narrow window of one to two weekends to
see big returns oh go bust so it's
essential new movies have the widest
appeal possible that means recognizable
characters simple plots are not too much
dialogue at least not of the complex or
intelligent variety but there's another
reason Studios wants as much predictable
revenue as possible today movies aren't
just competing with other movies they're
competing with books Netflix YouTube
social media video games they're
competing with your time and all the
other things you have to spend it on
short form entertainment such as
Instagram or YouTube are eating
traditional methods of entertainment
alive film is no exception this means
you have to sell your audience something
you already know they are going to want
how do you know what that is well you
simply find something that already
worked extremely well in another medium
such as books and turn it into a movie
franchise ie let's make a movie about
the boy wizard so to briefly summarize
largely due to the financial constraints
of moviemaking the need for huge and
instant returns and a modern environment
where everything competes for consumers
attention every
modern filmmaking has become a
wellspring of repetitive trite garbage
that pushes whatever talent is in the
industry into narrow predictable yet
marketable storytelling avenues and then
fine Tunes to product for mass appeal
mediocrity
one sort of positive side effect is that
more and more top talent flees to
Netflix and HBO where they feel more
rewarded and creatively free which is
why the quantity of top quality TV
series has skyrocketed over the past two
decades but it's a double-edged sword
for film lovers because movie studios
are left with second stringers making
second-string movies meaningless viewer
engagement which means less money and
more and more crap and so on it's a
snake eating its own tail make sense I'm
good now let's move on to storytelling
and this is where everything really
falls apart for a story to have
wide-reaching financial success it needs
to be easily understandable one way to
do this is to have it use a simple
familiar story structure that has been
proven to work though there are
exceptions the vast majority of modern
blockbusters can be boiled down to a
couple of simple self-evident and
totally worthless messages a team is
stronger than an individual if you
believe in yourself you will succeed
movies will drape their story in other
themes to provide diversity between
releases some of which are worthwhile
but when you really analyze them they
simply repeat these same messages that
we've been repeatedly told and have
internalized since childhood we already
know these axioms to be true we don't
need 20 movies a year to remind us
within these overarching themes writers
usually follow predictable free out
structures that screenwriting experts
such as Syd field have been promoting
and making money off
there's nothing new here they're all
largely rewritten and simplified
versions of Aristotle's Poetics and
Joseph Campbell's hero's journey whether
or not it has any artistic merit is
irrelevant what matters is that it sells
the free act structure goes something
like this act one person is in the
ordinary world feels X receives invites
to adventure or a challenge leaves the
ordinary world act two encounters
obstacle or enemy fails multiple times
keeps trying fails things are at their
very worst act free comes up with a new
plan rallies his strength overcomes
obstacle and or enemy feels y returns to
the ordinary world forever changed if
you really think about it most of
Hollywood's output can be boiled down to
this structure even if they play around
with the way the acts are presented or
the timeline it solar this alongside the
repetitive childish themes bring us back
to Scorsese's point what's not there is
revelation mystery or genuine emotional
danger nothing is at risk the pictures
are made to satisfy a specific set of
demands and they are designed as
variations on a finite number of themes
this is a more intellectual way of
saying predictable meaningless crap the
point is perhaps reinforced when
breakout movies like black panther come
along and are heralded as some sort of
divine seminal achievement
representation aside was it he followed
the same simple structure had the same
simple ideas and any other interesting
concepts such as the responsibilities of
those in power to their brothers without
weren't explored in any detail they were
icing on a simple cake hinting at
complexity was offering nothing
than approaching substance don't get me
wrong some of cinema's greatest movies
exclusively used the hero story from the
matrix to Fight Club but in these
examples and others the writers added
complexity and depth through intelligent
dialogue and unexpected plot devices a
Fight Club especially takes the hero's
journey and turns it upside down
so much so that spoiler alert the
protagonist turns out to be a
schizophrenic terrorist leader what I
despise is when writers rely solely on a
pre-established talk show with little
added depth or complexity to make a
movie yet this isn't even the worst sin
in hollywood's playbook that's award
goes solely to one thing Bay foes
forever shall its name be cursed 18th
century poet Alexander Pope coined the
phrase BAE false in his essay perry bay
fox or the art of sinking in poetry Pope
used baitfish to describe a technique
where a poet would suddenly change from
serious to trivial for the sake of
making the reader laugh even if it were
at the expense of the poem itself Pope
despised this as he felt it the based
poetry and prevented the art form and
topic of the poem from becoming
something greater and more transcendent
thank god they're not he didn't live to
see modern movies because beef us is
their favorite writing tool of all it's
incredible today how many movies no
matter their subject matter function
almost equally or even more so as
comedies
they are riddled with jokes often easily
translatable the visual gags as if the
writers and directors are terrified that
the audience might take their story
seriously for a second
one example that immediately comes to
mind is in Avengers infinity war where
Bruce Banner trips over like Looney
Tunes cartoon in what is the build-up to
a save the universal we're all doomed
battle that's like Michael Corleone
competing his satanic journey into
becoming the new Godfather only to cap
it off with him loudly breaking wind as
he renounces the devil the subject
matter is extremely serious well who
cares he is a joke
why is beef are so popular because humor
sells more accurately humor sells better
than art it's a sad truth but most of
your friends and family are much more
likely to go see a film if you recommend
it to their mouths it was funny it gave
me a lot of laughs it's a great day out
for the whole family rather than the
cinematography was exceptional the
acting was moving and the story was
gritty cast your mind back to their
recent releases you've seen from the
Hollywood movie machine and you'll find
it hard not to find examples where Bay
Falls is running wild often at the
expense of the pathos that is the
sincerity that evokes pity or sadness
necessary to a moving scene and if you
don't believe me just consider that the
average Marvel movie shoots out a joke
every 1 minute 18 seconds on average
considering that they're the benchmark
most of the Studios want to hit and that
their parent company Disney is
replicating their efforts at over 20
movies releasing this year it's going to
be a great year for undercut sincerity
and weak emotional integrity this
approach is really nailed home by a
quote from Buffy the Vampire Slayer
creator and Avengers director Joss
Whedon who said make it dark make it
grim make it tough but then for the love
of God tell a joke I don't have a
problem of humor in non comedy films in
fact I love it when it's done with class
but I'm a strong believer that it has to
come naturally or it just doesn't work
and it has to be appropriate to the tone
of the
Sene Tarantino has a particular knack
for this the opening scene of Reservoir
Dogs in the diner is speckled with funny
lines overwhelmingly about dicks and
wanting to shoot each other and it works
because it's just a bunch of criminals
shooting the [ __ ] over breakfast even
though they're about to pull off a jewel
heist you can imagine a similar
conversation happening in a similar
situation with similar people in real
life in Pulp Fiction when Vincent shoots
Marvin in the face even though they were
having a serious conversation about
Jules's retirement the comedy originated
from a slip of the finger an accident
but importantly it's one that seems
completely natural and appropriate to
these two low-budget hitman for hire the
way Vincent says oh man ah shucks Marvin
in the face is a hundred percent
befitting to his irreverent character
and it doesn't in any way detract from
the film's more serious underlying
message whereas there's nothing more out
of place and jarring than protagonists
making cheap jokes during an intense
knife fight to the death let me paint
another picture for you to demonstrate
how BAE Fox can ruin an otherwise great
film take 1987 predator starving Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's a blockbuster so
it's comparable to today's fair and
perhaps one of the most quotable and
beloved action movies of all time
predator tells a story of a team of
commandos who found themselves being
hunted and killed by a mysterious alien
warrior the movie is filled with
one-liners little notes of humor and the
reverence from the characters early on
but here's the thing as soon as they
start being slaughtered by a mysterious
invisible alien the characters cut that
[ __ ] out just like you I or any sane
human being would in fact one of the
most memorable lines from this part of
the movie is there something out there
waiting for us
a lady no man we're all gonna die uh
hardly a side-splitter but entirely
appropriate to the new mood and events
of the story this sincerity and
adherence to the appropriate tone leads
us to take the story in the situation
the characters are in more seriously we
see the villain as more of a threat and
it makes the final showdown a lot more
thrilling the result the creature has
become an indelible mainstay in popular
culture despite the fact it's only been
in one good movie to hammer this point
home the series was rebooted in 2018
filled with inappropriate Bayfest and
irreverence and the characters
throughout and was a commercial and
critical failure go figure
even when Hollywood is shown in consumer
trends that Bay foss isn't necessary to
succeed they try it anyway can you
imagine if in Titanic Kate Winslet
listening to Leo DiCaprio as frozen
impassioned final words told him to
chill I don't think it would have quite
the same effect the conclusion from this
is that not only are movies simplistic
and repetitive but they're devoid of the
necessary resonance to make them achieve
any kind of meaning or engagement sure
you might enjoy the spectacle you might
even enjoy the jokes but at what cost
because there's little more damaging to
the art of cinema than Bey false and the
abusive reliance on repetitive themes
and structures except perhaps how
politically minded executives are
cramming so-called progressive political
agendas into movies but that's a whole
other topic on that note all I have to
say is if you have an agenda don't
shoehorn it in at the expense of the
story
anyhow Ricky Gervais is already doing an
absolute sterling job of making a
laughingstock out of the woke Hollywood
elite so I don't have to I could also
join on about CJ Ivers practical effects
but I won't because the story comes
first the orcs in Peter Jackson's The
Hobbit may have looked like rubber sex
toys but at least it was redeemed by
Tolkien's time
story and Martin Freeman's acting
because whether you like it or not
stories are a form of communication and
they are in some way shape or form
edifying they are trying to teach you
something valuable but what do most
modern movie stories teachers the answer
is absolutely nothing they're shallow
fun that goes nowhere and leaves you
with nothing of value sure you might
feel like a rush to see The Avengers
band together to defeat the villain as
Alan Silvestri's music swells but what
are you left with what did you feel what
did you think or were you just left
wondering what will happen to these
corporate brands next this isn't to say
you can't make a large budget
blockbuster interesting The Dark Knight
is about resolving who you think you are
others who you need to be the Empire
Strikes Back is about how the evil we
see within others is just as much inside
us the Lord of the Rings is about how
meekness sacrifice and brotherly
fellowship can overcome the vices of
power and greed we can't help but be
affected by these themes when they're
well told as they are in these examples
but most modern movies don't do this
they're just commercials for the next
revenue generating insert studio brand
here adventure they're promoting a brand
that one's popular enough once enough
people have been to the cinema and
experienced us Scorsese said a visual
theme park ride they can be turned into
an actual theme park ride that can make
even more money so skip your next trip
to see Avengers parts 10
and gonna meet war and peace instead
you'll get much more out of it thanks
for watching
unfortunately I don't have a blockbuster
budget so if you enjoyed this video then
please consider supporting me on patreon
to help me to continue to make these
videos you'll find a link in the
description also you could get your
hands on a first edition signed copy of
my new book sticker fly get it by
heading on over to unban publishing the
links in the description i'm
pre-ordering your copy today thank you